et aux déclarations du président de la
république les fonctionnaires de police
sont vraiment en colère suite à ses
déclarations et ils veulent démontrer
aujourd'hui leur mécontentement le
problème m'étonne c'est que la police
derrière la halle manque de moyens la
police et le manque d'effectifs la
police manque d'eau plusieurs choses et
quand la police demande à avoir des
choses nous ne l'entend pas il est par
contre de l'autre côté on descend la
police
et ça ça je trouve ça se peut que ça un
cube a fini par expliquer sur le gâteau
brut que la police est raciste il
stigmatise en gros que tous mes
collègues sont racistes et qu'une infime
partie de mes collègues arabes et noirs
pourraient ne pas l'être
enfin c'est comme ça que je le perçois
c'est comme cette mes collègues le
perçoit et aujourd'hui moi je peux le
garantir mes collègues mes collègues ne
sont pas racistes
et aujourd'hui si ils manifestent ils
continueront à manifester c'est pour
justement soulevé et démontrer qu'ils ne
sont pas racistes
et non il n'y a pas de contrôles au
faciès dans la police